hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me Jane second Kevin McGuire and Roy
nikka are here to look back at the
biggest stories over the last seven days
would be new top stories well John I
think it's great news miss understand
insolent but one of the government
bribed them with mm- definitely donald
trump's hollywood walk of fame star
being smashed by a sledgehammer or more
on both of those in a second but first
our top story of the week after more
than a decade of waiting the plan for a
third runway at heathrow was given
clearance for takeoff but in its wake it
left political division and resignation
is our political editor feisal Islam it
is the airport with the most traffic in
Europe but right now he throws runways
are no longer the busiest in the world
after more than a decade of fudge the
government finally deciding on an extra
run way here this is a project that will
demonstrate very clearly to the world
that Britain is open for business post
breaks it it's a project that will open
up opportunities around the United
Kingdom but that calls this the former
mayoral candidate Zac Goldsmith
fulfilling his promise to quit as a
Richmond MP forcing a delicate
by-election for the government I've
resigned as your Member of Parliament
and I'll be standing in the by-election
as an independent candidate this
election must be a referendum on
Heathrow expansion the lib dems though
see a referendum on Briggs it instead
and mindful of that the Conservatives
extraordinarily not even fighting a seat
they won by 23,000 only last year
perhaps that is why he sounds rather
confidence people here feel is strongly
about the issues either there's no way
you could have a referendum on Heathrow
and you'd have Jim Bob winners results
almost everyone is opposes the
government accepted what it called
world-leading assurances on pollution
and noise but local councils will take
it to judicial review so a new terminal
and a new runway jus in to land near
decades time do you think it was the
right decision Kevin no I Devon forgot
wick I know that area quite well as 800
homes
bulldoze many thousands more will be
blighted so much pollution and
congestion already around there and it's
interesting that now they've got the
green light the people behind Heathrow
they're already trying to cut back how
much they're going to spend on it and
there are big challenges to this idea
that we somehow gain 141 billion which
is an invented figure well you know that
even been wrought back against exact
groaning yeah too didn't he you couldn't
really get back from that promise he
absolutely had to him it was his
manifesto pledge he'll run as an
independent Tory's have said come out of
there not going to fight that seat I
think the only question for him is that
he may it's now turned out that you Kip
are going to back him and I think that
was something he may come to regret and
watch distance himself from and but I'm
absolutely sure given the issues he's
fighting on its his constituency that's
so affected he will walk that planet
livid not constituency I think the lib
dems will run in very close historically
it was live demos it so and there the
big economic news this week Nissan you
mentioned at the beginning a great vote
of confidence in the Sun Berlin planted
a story about confidence of industry and
breaks it no absolutely it's a released
seven thousand jobs directly many more
in suppliers and so like eighty percent
of the cars of half a million or so a
year or export it but what have the
government had to give miss angers and
this I'm have been playing tough they've
got something the government's not
telling us you're gonna get other
companies Jaguar Land Rover Honda Toyota
a BMW they all come along with the
manufacturers to so I think in the
interest of transparency the commercial
come clean okay well those were our top
news stories on a busy news week but
here are five things that you might have
missed central Italy was hit by another
earthquake just two months after one
which left large areas devastated
fortunately nobody was killed in the
tremors on Wednesday night but it
brought down buildings left weakened by
August's quake
the security forces are pretty convinced
that some members of Islamic state will
try to get out of the various villages
and towns and of course modal that
they've been holding to carry out
attacks amongst the displaced people
chief correspondent Stewart Ramsey
followed the Iraqi Army's advance
towards mosel progress was slowed by the
burning oil fields torched by Islamic
state and the ever-increasing
humanitarian crisis
pete Burns the sing when the pop group
Dead or Alive should i do it yeah Gorman
you don't live at the age of 57 I'm sure
he would approve after suffering a heart
attack he shot to fame in the 80s but
was most recently known for his stint on
Celebrity Big Brother also this week a
protester took a sledgehammer to Donald
Trump's star on the hollywood walk of
fame at roy as punching the air a man
dressed as a construction worker said he
damaged the monument to try to remove
the star that he could auction it to
raise funds for the women who've accused
that the Republican presidential
candidate of sexual assault and from one
would be needed to another four hour gap
of the week and for some this stunt was
the moment ed miliband lost the election
but even now almost 18 months on the
edge stone still hangs around Labour's
neck the monument to Miliband cost more
than seven and a half thousand pounds at
the time cost the party further 20,000
after they failed to declare it on their
election spending return it was Kevin
Ed's Moses moment we live it down never
it'll be with him all the way and it did
symbolize why he wasn't going to win
that election because conservatives have
got their own problems with expenses bus
to us we don't quite know what happened
to it do we know when industrial estate
yeah they try to hide it was gonna be
ground down but it's whether he could
get it out the storage unit without
people see it hit and taking photographs
of it I'm sure it'll be nice all of it
and somebody's I have to say it's not
probably in a minute band household no
Kip uses a table or something turnover
use the back of it something to scrub on
it some Nauts mm-hmm don't forget send
us your nominations for gap of the week
using the hashtag W in our now this week
the so-called jungle at Calais home to
thousands of migrants and refugees began
to be demolished skies mark stone was
there for us early morning on the edge
of the jungle everything appeared to be
going well at least that's what the
authorities were claiming we watched the
numbers swell quickly and in the line
for under-18s many most undoubtedly were
they were supposed to have been
registered first but they're still
waiting
their night had been spent here a jungle
that had been a blaze for several hours
yet amid the mess the chief of police in
charge of all this told us it was all
now under control but an hour later this
place is taking hold across the camp in
such a cramped space they spread quickly
many are still living here adults and
children some unwilling to leave most
just unable to register those children
who have registered have been housed
here an area that the authorities said
would be safe and secure it's not in
just one brief chat with one young man
you get a clear sense of the multiple
layers of misery here sometimes I asked
her to God please God kill me because
he's a dirty life this is Europe I don't
think so this is not Europe and now the
only place they could call home has gone
roya it has been officially cleared now
but it's clear that there are still
quite a number of migrants in that area
that the French haven't succeeded in
getting rid of all the people who are
living there no they haven't I think
they've done a pretty good job I mean
there's been certain minimal violence
and disruption I'm clearing that site
but it is worrying that we're hearing
that on the ground they are still around
a thousand people if you know the
children still still there and I'm local
MPs have said you know it is up to the
French government to act responsibly and
find out what they're going to do with
them and amber Rudd again cause keeps
reminding France they need to take
responsibility for those migrants she
listened anyway we'll stop the problem
of migrants traveling through Europe
trying to cross the channel either
getting onto glories or getting onto
boats or trying just trying to get here
I suspect not completely jenga's there
is still the problem of people who fled
terror or terrible conditions and
they're in Europe that camp was a stain
on the whole of Europe not just France
and some of the one to come to Britain
because they will have relatives or they
will have friends there with no people
they will speak English and if they come
argue once again and they make a
contribution Britain they don't come
from benefit they come to work and there
will be people there who will be the
leaders of the future and they will be
people with great talent and potential
but we can use it does also beg the
question Roy there over to do this in
two and a half days why they didn't do
it earlier you're absolutely right it
does i think it sounded like there was
so much tension between the french
government hey you know amber Rudd last
week in the house saying that actually
despite what the French was saying her
officials couldn't even get into the
camp until last week to find out how
many children were there Francine that
wasn't the case at all this should have
been done a long time ago for the
migrants sake and I think the French and
British government's need to work much
more closely on this problem okay right
quick quiz for you both now can you tell
me who's been criticized for indulging
people's sweet tooth do you know at home
we'll find out after the break
we can review with me Jane second i'm
joined by kevin maguire associate editor
of The Daily Mirror and the journalist
Roya nika now before the break we asked
who's been criticized for indulging
people's sweet teeth and you know I
think I know is it the Prince of Wales
and has ice cream which has been accused
of having way too much sugar is sworn
enemy of dentists Prince Charles his ice
cream which is a Dutch original sold in
waitrose has twice the amount of sugar
that other ice creams similar it's
nothing sweet about this freeloader is
they argued it's a luxury product that
it's not aimed at children and that
there are other lower sugar available
for the lower orders the little people
the beauty is very pleased by his next
joke when she's written me to say which
is it means he's not just the makers of
crowns for your head so bad right okay
moving on ahhhh groaning at home this
week two bakers who refused to make a
cake with a message supporting gay
marriage lost an appeal against the
ruling that their actions amounted to
discrimination skies David Levin's
reports Gareth Lee had gone to this
Belfast bakery to order a cake iced with
a slogan supporting gay marriage Asher's
was found to have discriminated by
refusing to bake it but Daniel and Amy
MacArthur the Christian couple who run
the business have told Sky News they
feel the law has discriminated against
them on the basis of their faith we're
disappointed with with the way it went
and here's me that they didn't
considered how much our conscience
affects us as Christians and just in
high weed on their business and but we
we still believe that God is in control
do you have any sympathy for mr. Lee and
for others from the LGBT community who
sometimes feel victimized in Northern
Ireland we never meant to cause anyone
any offense and
but at the same time as Christians we
certainly felt victimized by the
equality Commission of Northern Ireland
the equality Commission for Northern
Ireland who brought the case on behalf
of the customer welcomed the appeal
court judgment upholding the original
verdict Asher's bakery had unlikely
support from gay rights campaigner Peter
Tatchell he branded the verdict
dangerous authoritarian and a defeat for
freedom of expression and do you think
it's right that they lost this appeal
should that should they be allowed to
refuse to bake anything or should they
be forced to bake something against
their will no they're right not too big
a king no come on otherwise you'll start
turning away people you just don't like
or agree with equally they wouldn't have
baked a cake with the swear word on us
or they wouldn't have baked a cake with
a rude message on it or something that
was discriminated against somebody else
they said they wouldn't have ate that
either yeah but there was nothing rude
or sweary about that it's a kind of
straw argument isn't it just put up to
knock down know if you if you allowed
this you would then allow B&B owners to
say you're not going to allow gays or
electricians or plumbers or all people
like we live in it we live in a very
open tolerant society and that requires
it to be tolerant of other people and
they were going to discriminate against
these two gay they argue though that
they're not discriminating against them
because they're gay they said they make
bade kick made cakes lots of gay people
before they just don't want to make a
cake with a pro game message I hear what
they're saying but I would never
criticize someone for having strong
faith which clearly they do but to hear
them talk about feeling discriminated
and victimized for the judgment that
just it was I just thought that was a
little bit ridiculous I totally agree
with Kevin on this I think it's wrong to
start turning away people on the basis
of their sexuality or anything and
particularly in this country where gay
marriage is legal now this is very great
thing yeah these beggars want their cake
and eat it if they think they can run a
business and then discriminate against
some people you can't okay on to your
choices of top paper stories of the week
Roy was started with you another a
pretty spicy week in the world of you
Kip another ridiculous week in the world
of you Kip as Kevin quarter Mike right
hukum yes I mean there's wood
you can prefer fan Stephen wolf who
accuse Mike hookem alleged that he
thrown a punch their investigation has
found that he didn't and that actually
Steve wolf started his so he said she
said it's ridiculous this party is now
completely at the center point of
collapse I Stephen wolf you know going
into this it formally don't made his bit
of the leadership is now still talking
about would he possibly defect to the
Tories I think the Tories would have him
after all the best it's May you can't
look even more ridiculous than it did
before if that was possible I think that
was possible but it's like just trying
trying to separate squabbling toddlers
isn't it exactly oh it is that mean the
run from an industrial state near newton
abbot and was it fertile either they're
trying to get in a matter of matter of
months but it's incredibly they won the
big one on the brexit thought and they
fallen apart since perhaps because
they've got no real reason to exist
anymore or the bmd migrant and should
the French authorities investigate
though Nigel Farage's point is you know
when you're in the European Parliament
you shouldn't really be under French law
yeah point doesn't he now we are we
gonna claim crown immunity or something
and you know you're a subjective the
majesty so now you've got to abide by
the laws of the country you're in When
in Rome do as romans do should they
investigate their worked it depends what
wolf and you know right hukum think
about really rather than shorts okay
well that that's how quick listen to
Schultz today mr. verba made defamatory
statement against me which you supported
can I ask that both you gentlemen leave
this building where you don't have
parliamentary immunity and repeat those
statements so i can take legal action
against you I would have no problem at
all with seeing you in court i'll be
very pleased to do so it just goes on it
does those kind of exchanges do they
make the european parliament look
ludicrous and i think they should be
aware which he keeps very happy about
i'm sure yeah but over the last time
right you can went outside of it we know
what happened with wolf fun so if I was
Schultz I just stay where I am yeah okay
let's move on quickly Kevin warning
about Lady birds and these aren't a
British lady Bozize are foreign Lee I
know you can will we get upset about
this yeah the Harlequin ladybirds been
flown in butter blown in I suppose from
from Asia and North America
in their millions and they're just
appear in covering houses and cars and
they're different because they're black
they've got they've got black wings with
red dots instead of red wings I try it's
the opposite or to a sturdy local
ladybird but they've got some sexually
transmitted disease now boo love Benny
Alice and to fungal disease and it kills
the red-backed lady by my side because I
think they're marvelous they're they're
marvelous insect lily birds but I think
I prefer to see one or two they also
apparently leave a hot nasty smell when
they're in large groups and leave stains
on furniture all together quite
unpleasant least most invasive lady bird
species on earth if you see a swarm of
the more of your call the collective
noun shut your windows roya and let's
move on body is cremation a pretty hot
topic in the church this week well at
Francis who until sort of this decision
has seemed like a very forward-looking
tolerant pope catholic churches made a
decision that actually I'm Catholic
shouldn't be able to scatter the ashes
of their loved ones what's DEKRA mated
or how are you I think it all divided
them up or keep them at home keep menaka
keep them in sort of bowser's because
they feel cavity search the side of it
because they feel this is too much like
scattering them is too much like
naturalism or Nile agonism veganism and
I think you know a growing numbers of
Catholics are choosing to cremate their
loved ones and scatter their ashes for
economic reasons for ecological reasons
and they should be allowed to do that
and I think the Catholic Church is
completely wrong to try and make its
followers feel guilty for how they want
to commemorate their loved ones also
it's trying to becoming of is that
there's a lot that the Catholic Church
could be tattling a lot of problems that
exist within religion around the world
and i'm not i'm not sure this is one of
the greater ones no i think we did the
top ten thousand it wouldn't wouldn't
make it would it and what are the thing
of all these bits of ashes are going to
come you know together at the rio and
Christ rises or something look people
get a lot of comfort of taking the ashes
of a loved one to scatter them in a
beauty spot or at a river on the sea
wherever it was they used to like to go
and I just think it's barmy absolutely
barneys leave it alone if that's ok
that's how people get peace of mind
they don't have that piece of okay Kevin
also this week is the world word super
still so super super like Roya thinks
it's an evening meal super tell you but
it seems it seems the I think it's the
Oxford English Dictionary they figure
it's used too often no nothing some
people all say you know all right all
right there's a lot of use of super I
don't use it my soul super rich super
fast I mean superfast broadband people
talk about that is part of the language
yeah but that's that's an accurate
description it's when people use super
gotta say that was a super goal a super
t or a super TV program they just super
super super super likes a certain
especially adding of it it's an
adjective being proof yea big smile at a
very special across about I blame super
knew I like the word well see Fabio
Thank You Tina raspy kiss anyway oh
you're so cheeky thank you very much for
taking us through the papers what about
your ups and downs that Roy was starting
with you this week and you're sending up
Christopher Marlowe is finally got his
name written on it on a Shakespeare yes
hooray for kit Marlowe I think this is a
wonderful story actually the new oxford
addition of some plays of Shakespeare's
particularly it's the Henry the sixth
place yeah pocket into and driving to
credit kit Marlowe as co-author
centuries of debate over how much
co-authoring Shakespeare did the pirius
would always like to say here everything
himself I'm vast so the bank of scholars
to come together and analyze these texts
and decided that actually no I'm
Christopher Marlowe was working with
Shakespeare and actually i think this
doesn't detract anything at all from
Shakespeare's genus it adds to it it as
to the story of these two being rivals
and probably exceptionally good friends
too but it also shows how clever
Shakespeare or greatest player ever was
to work with and collaborate with
someone whose genius like Chris
fermanagh by building Chris from now
I'll be like me Gilbert and Sullivan
other time belk it shall be good feel
good right super we'll send it up you're
sending download this week roya wet
wipes and their effect on our sewer
system yes
this is a body of UK water companies who
have written to advertising stands
agencies and other bodies asking them to
more clearly label and wet wipes as
non-disposable because apparently there
are around 88 well it's not it's not the
baby wipes that the people use it's the
flushable toilet wipes that are that are
marketed as flushable both and they are
flushable yeah it's both lush them there
yeah they cause these blockages only 88
million pounds worth of customers money
is being spent clearing these boxes
every year I agree that perhaps labeling
has part to play but I think consumers
need to be a little bit more savvy and
use a bit more common sense about what
isn't-isn't flushable disposable I think
sometimes with some wipes it's quite
clear that you know synthetic whites
probably are not going to be
biodegradable I can tell you it's
somebody blocked off trains using it
none of them would own up well
everything's family yeah go on as good
as a bill appear yo girl he was gonna
give a copy of the garden didn't you I
did artist to find the man who love a
person who'll cover yeah because the
plumber wouldn't do it then the plumber
went into it there was a man called as
fast as well doesn't it where they block
the sewers and then the fat congeals and
performs this big fabric lovely is a
great subject hope we haven't put you
off your dinner or your sunday lunch and
the right so we're sending that down you
there Kevin are setting up the new boss
of John Lewis Paula Nichols yeah hurrah
well startling a haberdashery 22 years
ago and now the md got at the top and I
suppose when we stopped noticing women
getting top jobs it'll be any era of
equality it's just there are so few in
company so good luck to her she's she
has worked our way up yeah the graduate
trainee who as you say start on the shop
floor worked in haberdashery and but
he's had some big success isn't she
she's the one that was feed behind all
the tear-jerking ads in the last few
years yeah I have John news is currently
yeah they have the work here oh no I
just did all that sucker and plastics
you know that don't get it right we're
sending her up and you're sending down
equally grumpy but I agree with you on
this one the selfie stick hurrah but
you've been around 11 years but sales
are finally plummeting are they percent
sales are down by which one store there
for sure armed people who are
unembarrassed balazs they hold and I
often see them in central London you
just saw walkthrough him now but
don't hate them and but apparently we're
in the majority seventy percent of the
country in a survey thing that they are
annoying annoying in that yeah so
they're going bye-bye to the selfie sick
we won't miss you bringing and sending
it down thank you both thanks very much
for taking us through and don't forget
do send us your nominations at using the
hashtag w it in our for ups and downs
well thank you very much for joining us
for our review of the week we'll be back
with much more next week but for now
it's goodbye from then goodbye and it's
goodbye from me goodbye